Attorney General Jeff Sessions has been
fired by Donald Trump protests already
planned all over the country for 5:00
p.m. local time this afternoon you might
be wondering why am I saying fired
because there are some reports that say
resigned there are other reports that
say forced out the bottom line is that
Donald Trump wasn't pleased with Jeff
Sessions dating all the way back to 2017
and ultimately it's up to Trump whether
Jeff Sessions remains Attorney General
or does not and there is every
indication from the reports that it was
Trump's decision to force Attorney
General Jeff Sessions out this has
everything to do with the Trump Russia
investigation and Robert Muller we will
talk about that the legal implications
as well as the interim or acting
replacement for Jeff Sessions where to
start
I guess with what Donald Trump said and
not unexpected in many ways this was a
predictable firing even the timing we
could argue was predictable and what
Donald Trump said on Twitter is that we
are pleased to announce that Matthew G
Whittaker
chief of staff to Attorney General Jeff
Sessions at the Department of Justice
will become our new acting Attorney
General of the United States he will
serve our country well we thank Attorney
General Jeff Sessions for his service
and wish him well a permanent
replacement will be nominated at a later
date the day after the election because
Trump knows or was advised more likely
that if he does it before the midterms
people might change their votes
realizing that this is part of Donald
Trump's plan to interfere with Robert
Muller's investigation period former FBI
Special Agent Asha ranga tweeting
earlier today that even this firing
would potentially be relevant to a case
against Trump for objection obstruction
of justice and in fact right before the
tweets about the firing donald trump
tweeted about robert muller
as the last tweet before firing Jeff
sessions and as usual referring to the
Russia investigation as a witch-hunt so
it's as if we needed that to realize
that these issues are related and the
timing of the tweets the timing of the
firing everything about this is making
it very very clear and in general things
that you do hours after an election are
done that way specifically because you
identify that there's risk to doing it
that way before the election also
interesting acting Attorney General
we're gonna talk about Matthew Whitaker
in a second but the idea of putting in
an acting Attorney General it could be a
long time until a permanent Attorney
General is put in and the difficulty of
that confirmation might actually be part
of Donald Trump's plan to keep an acting
Attorney General in for a long time as
long as possible potentially depending
on what happens with Robert molars Trump
Russia probe and part of why it might be
difficult if Trump's plan is to
eventually put in Matthew Whitaker
specifically as Attorney General that
could be made difficult by the reality
that Whitaker literally wrote an op-ed
for CNN arguing against the Moller
investigation and explaining how he
would go about shutting it down
understand this and we're showing the
article that he wrote some months ago to
our television and YouTube audience the
guy who is taking over for Jeff Sessions
has publicly stated how he would end the
Moller investigation which he believes
goes too far and he would do it
basically by starving it a funding which
is the common right-wing tactic we've
seen them try to do this with Obama care
we've seen them try to take apart
welfare programs by simply starving them
a funding and that's exactly what
Matthew Whitaker says he would do so
first and foremost Pat this particular
timing is very obvious in terms of what
it means and then he's putting in not
someone who might be hostile to the
investigation but someone who is on the
record as being hostile to the
investigation and
having a specific plan as to how he
would end it and chop-chop - I don't
think they'd have too much time that
they can waste I think that's why was
fired immediately because it seems from
Muller's team that they were going to
come out with some of their findings
after the midterm elections maybe some
indictments are underway soon - like
Donald Trump jr. even Jared Kushner
Roger stone those names have been
mentioned so they have to do it all very
very quick and I think that the story is
going to end pretty soon you think that
the investigation in other words is
going to be coming to a close soon and
that thus part of I mean that that would
be an argument for the sort of futility
of even doing this because I've read a
few analyses which say if indeed Moeller
is getting ready to wrap this up then
changing Attorney General now - one
who's not recused on Russia potentially
wouldn't even really do that much
because we may already have all the
indictments prepared prepared already
and that that sort of is a question
there is both an urgency and also a
possible futility and it's important to
understand that even though sessions was
beleaguered as we as / Trump as we've
heard many times partially for recusing
himself on all Russia related matters
after being caught lying about his own
contacts with Russia I will remind you
he was actually a loyal trumpet in
Trump's administration in a sense and
the the unfortunate reality if your
Trump is that Matthew Whitaker also
should recuse himself on anything
related to Trump Russia because he's
tied up in it with an op-ed explaining
how he would end an investigation that
he doesn't think should be going on in
the first place and in fact Nancy Pelosi
has already called for Matthew Whitaker
to replace him - to recuse himself even
though Trump has been slamming sessions
time and time again sessions stuck with
it and it's not totally clear yet
whether Matthew Whitaker is going to be
an effective sort of roadblock for this
investigation a few reminders of the
long and troubled history between Donald
Trump and Jeff Sessions you will
remember the tweet where Donald Trump
said Attorney General Jeff Sessions has
taken of
a weak position on hillary clinton
crimes where our emails and DNC server
and Intel leakers yes grammatically
confusing but publicly criticizing his
Attorney General not something you
normally see presidents do and then
maybe the first example of the public
strife between Trump and Jeff Sessions
was a tweet in February where Donald
Trump said why is AG Jeff Sessions
asking the Inspector General to
investigate potentially massive FISA
abuse will take forever has no
prosecutorial power and already late
with reports on Comey
etc isn't the IG an Obama guy why not
use Justice Department lawyers
disgraceful and more about the message
sent by a president criticizing their
own Attorney General than the content
because the content was was mostly
mostly nonsense it's also important to
consider the implications of Jeff
Sessions being fired because sessions
was in a way not just one of the loyal
original trumpets but the last remaining
major link to establishment
republicanism and we've talked about
that before Pat and I think that's even
a point that you've made in the past
which is that sessions is not a sort of
Bannen Sarah Huckabee Sanders Kushner
type that he is an actual and he's also
not a military type he is a guy from the
establishment Republican base who was
there with Trump and now that link has
been severed as well yeah he's more of
an establishment type and how ironic is
that that left-wing groups are going to
be protesting his firing all across the
country this is the guy that said that
good people don't smoke marijuana that
he used to like the KKK until he found
out that they smoke pot something like
that you know terrible record on
criminal justice reform and now because
politics makes strange bedfellows we're
all rallying to his to his support well
I think what's important to point out
there is that progressives who and
sensible Republicans who are going to
protest today because of this firing
they're not doing it because they agree
with Jeff Sessions politics and I think
it that it's actually refreshing
way that what is being protested here is
an attempt to get in the way of the
normal course of justice and to get in
the way of the checks and balances that
we have and it is it's it's interesting
because without defending anything that
Jeff Sessions stands for politically you
can still identify as all of the
thousands and thousands of protesters
who will be out today and I'm going to
stop by the protest in downtown Boston
myself they are out there because of
what this represents and by the way you
mentioned Pat the weed stuff Jeff
sessions was one of the bigger
escalators of the war on drugs and if
there is any silver lining politically
in sessions firing its that maybe his
firing will deflate some of those Trump
Justice Department plans to resk elate
the war on drugs which actually would be
great now on the merits can Matthew
Whitaker the acting Attorney General as
per trump replaces replacing Jeff
Sessions can he stop the Moller
investigation he can certainly use
different tactics to try and this is
where Democrats need to come down on
them if they do they might be able to
interfere with the investigation before
the new Congress is inaugurated which
will include a democratically controlled
house and that also may be part of the
urgency there's a few different reads as
to the immediate timing right after the
2018 midterms midterm elections and
what's very clear is that they aren't
going to go quietly this is going to be
insane for years this all very
transparently relates to the Russia
probe which we're going to get to next
because Trump's lawyers according to
Politico have been advising Donald Trump
to wait a little bit before firing Jeff
Sessions hoping to get more information
from Muller about what is in his
findings and what is in his report
Donald Trump clearly has ignored that
advice and after the break were going to
talk about breaking news related to the
Russia probe Pat alluded to it Donald
Trump jr. now reportedly telling friends
that he believes an indictment is
imminent soon expecting it send me your
thoughts on the firing of
sessions get in touch if you're joining
one of these protests around the country
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and the show
is on Twitter at David Pakman show